faut bien s'hydrater ah oui donc on se
lève le matin on fait quoi en se levant
bah oui oui c'est logique et nécessaire
donc d'accord si on fait pas pipi de
matin c'est qu'un problème ah oui plutôt
et vraiment dense on ignore donc si on
élimine s'accorder pas prêt j'ai fais
pipi
là je suis bien je suis tout nu chez cas
je fais quoi et habille justement là
frédéric bulot charbon une douche c'est
bien même on peut l'apprendre froide ça
part mal quand on prend une douche
froide
ça fait un petit frisson ma soeur on
perd des calories donc booste son
immunité ça fait du bien
or on améliore le retour veineux et en
plus sauf un choc thorfinn on voit la
vie en rose
une douche froide
ouais je veux faire ça après déjeuner
pour l'été des stages personnellement au
petit déjeuner je boive juste beaucoup
de thé vert d'accord et puis voilà ça ça
reste quoi c'est une même cartouche on
est dur même pas un petit sarko show off
brouiller une connerie si près si on a
faim seulement on est obligé de jouer
avec le maintenant relève le matin j'ai
une faim de loup avait regardé du tennis
toute la nuit en plus ya l'open
d'australie en ce moment je vous laisse
j'ai eu l'impression que j'ai joué dans
toutes façons je me lève sur rhône au
générique on dit souvent le premier
repas le premier repas c'est le plus
important c'est ce qu'on voulait le
matin à toulon doit le rencontrer en
action le petit déjeuner de roi ouais
ouais
non alors c'est quoi c'est des conneries
ça non le point important c'est le jeune
jeunes à oui oui alors là je faisant
parler parce que j'ai le jeu essentiel
être à jeun le point clé c'est pas ce
qu'on mange c'est quand manche d'accord
et là on a une découverte extraordinaire
c'est que toutes les religions du monde
en parlait depuis le début de l'humanité
il ya trois ans à prix nobel japonais
repères aussi le truc est en fait c'est
le jeune séquentiel en fait c'est une
bonne nouvelle on a découvert l'élixir
de jouvence
donc il faut faire ramadan alors qu'est
ce que c'est exactement le jeune
séquentielle qu'est ce qu'il faut
pendant 14 heures oui on arrête de
manger on boit beaucoup d'aidé de l'onu
et c'est vrai alors c'est très technique
parce qu'on peut monter à 16h 18h 20h il
faut pas manger jusqu'à 14 heures après
ses aveux 10 heures durée maximum man 2
0t mort s'accordent pour beaucoup c'est
ce qu'on mange avant après la façon
aussi va t il ya un mode d'emploi j'en
parle dans ce livre mais c'est très
important pourquoi ce mode d'emploi
parce que le jeune à 4 actions saab ou
son immunité
tous les jours on fabrique des cellules
cancéreuses on exposait des virus des
toxi et ça monte notre immunité faut pas
oublier qu'à pas de médicaments pour
monter l'immunité
on se défend beaucoup mieux on chute
l'inflammation
donc on est moins sujet aussi aux
maladies une nouvelle incroyable
ces combats au sol à l'hormone de
croissance jusqu'à 3000 % c'est anti
vieillissement en plus au niveau
cérébral
on va sécréter du bbf c'est une hormone
récompense plus vite plus rapide mais en
plus certains des concours au programme
de cette façon là c'est une façon ces
dix organe qui se mettront en route des
hormones des enzymes c'est un vrai
ballon en fait le conseil ces voix là il
faut jeûner pendant 14 heures mais c'est
bien se marrer cvo docteur
13h 14h à 20h ou 21h et 14 heures après
ça veut dire que jamais surtout ils sont
jamie lee il suffit de faire l'essai
d'arrêter deux manches et devra écarter
commençant l'énergie au lieu d'être
utilisait digéré les fêtes pour se
réparer pour régénérer à c'est très
important de lutter contre notre
obsolescence programmée alors les cinq
astuces du docteur saldmann pourra être
mieux
voilà je vous lis pour être plus
performant pour être en meilleure santé
plus fort en cinq ans on commence avec
une astuce pour les gens qui veulent
perdre du poids manger des gâteaux au
chocolat peut faire maigrir qu'est ce
que c'est que cette histoire
alors là amenez moi les granola mémoire
de ces deux études qui sont sortis les
dernières étonnante on est allé en zone
interdite pour trouver comment mesquer
bref maigrir en faisant ce qui fait
plaisir non alors qu'est ce qui se passe
quand on fait un régime entre
parenthèses 95% des gens qui veulent
m'écrire aux grossistes ouais la cançon
de maigrir que le métabolisent se
ralentit qu on veut garder et en plus
l'appétit monte à bien sûr quand on a
fait de l'étude
en même temps des gâteaux et ben les
gens ont le métabolisme qui s'accélère
qui brûle plus et la leptine l'hormone
de la satiété monte alors il ya des
recettes de gâteaux dont j'ai parlé un
implant tu as au chocolat essayez vous
allez voir c'est très facile à faire et
on perd du poids space caire à pizza ouf
ça on peut dire à sophie koch qu'elle
est passée avait peur on enchaîne avec
un sujet que vous abordez aussi dans
votre livre concernant jeunes dont vous
l'avez dit faire un jeune de 14 heures
permet de rajeunir
voilà quatorze heures nos jeunes c'est
possible oui moi je mangeais possible
c'est comme si dans une vie on avait un
nombre de repas limité à prendre quand
on mange trop on suce trop vite quand on
mange trop su ce trou toutes les
religions depuis le début de tuer je
comprends pourquoi castaldi a fait comme
j'aime
depuis le début du magny départ du jaune
comme un message du fond de la nuit des
temps c'est vraiment ses ex 31 fait les
frais de main moi je vais perdre on
devrait alors en trois mois qui
troisième astuce c'est pour la grosse
commission il faut rester aux toilettes
pendant trois minutes
ni plus ni moins mais ça veut dire que
toto la tuque renault m parce que si on
reste moins de temps qui se passe ça va
trop vite alors par bien ce qu'ils
veulent faire
elle pousse et en poussant sa donne la
pression artérielle qui monte ouvrez des
accidents vasculaires sûr il ya des
accidents vasculaires de genthod propre
histoire et savait ce qu'il faut faire
pour mettre un petit coup de mou rêve
soulever ses jambes et sur la côte où va
le conduire
et pour ça pour les gens âgés il ya
souvent un téléphone à côté des
toilettes s'est fait mal exactement et
c'est vrai ben voilà on sait pas qui
appeler on appelle quelqu'un il
m'appelle est en train de bien je suis
pas fière et donc frédéric donc docteur
don danser alors quand on fait trop vite
c'est pas bon pas bon et quand on fait
trop lentement qu'est ce qui se passe et
qui y viennent avec des livres détailla
les mets qui ont débuté les petites
contractions qui permette que s'avance
s'arrête le sphincter anal n'a pu sa
tonicité qu'il faut résultat laisse les
matières au monde
il se décèle ac elysée maury parfois
sorte c'est pas esthétique
qu'est ce qu'un mathieu à ce passionné
par la médecine l isolement du tout
goûté aux ports et aux non mais c'est
vrai mais non mais c'est très
intéressant d'aller si on a pas finis ou
3000 da oui avec toi même
c'est très rare qu'on n'est pas terminé
aux trois demis soirée celui qu'il n'y a
pas deux premiers cas pas terminé trois
buts il faut qu'ils aillent consulter
quoi qu'il arrive à on continue avec une
astuce sexuelle et pour après le sexe ne
tournez pas le dos à votre partenaire
sexuel pourquoi alors on a découvert que
les pendants pas vraiment pas mal on
observait que quand les couples après
l'acte sexuel c'est pas un café
l'addition way se mettent en petite
cuillère l'un contre l'autre pendant un
quart d'heure en cuillère quoi ambac
soit le cas les couples à un quart
d'heure car d'un quart d'heure et bocar
durant tu te dire actuelle est beaucoup
plus apprécié ça prolonge le destin et
oui autant que l'acte sexuel lui à wes
est étonnant vous soumettre à une petite
cuillère c'est fini car c'est vrai il a
raison je m'attends petite cuillère oui
vous mettez en ville ou sous
[Rires]
et en cuir le voir quelqu'un battu une
seconde dit qu ils sont partenaires
après pas vous mais moi j'ai pas
l'intention de prolonger notre mesure
moi je connais ma propre et non moi non
mais oh alors oui sophy non je sprinte
beaucoup oui je sprinte bout et cody
bass et sans la cuillère tu sais ça
s'appelle comme ça la position c'est
aussi ça va nous raconte je vois
tellement pas fait tellement pas jeter
au parlement tic tata pas la bonne porte
ah bah non pas moi à sa façon je
l'attends arrêté ce mardi moi j'ai pas
dit oui
même position pour prolonger en cuillère
avec fatouma bah oui c'est vrai bah oui
on est belle pour ça alors le problème à
davos herawi ah oui là où avant avant
que l'ipad jean pierre coffe est la pète
l'accueillir une vague l'année dernière
la bouche
ah ouais bah ouais ouais c'est clair toi
avec ton mec après bah oui je pense que
j'aime pas les garçons qui sont égoïstes
et qui pensent qu'à eux sont mineurs on
rentre chez moi je crois taxi je vais
dormir non c'est pas cool taxi alors
d'avoir très dormir kelly dont je
rentrais chez moi
moi je pense que si c'est de l'amour
bien sûr qu'il faut se câliner après
pour sa re décembre parce qu'en fait ça
monte ça monte ça monte quand on est au
sommet il faut aussi faire en sorte que
ça redescende bien comme c'est bien
monté alors ils venus commercialise de
tout mais sa luge de la mer qu'elle
salue ce concept
donc après faut prendre son temps pour
faire redescendre et pour se câliner se
donner de l'amour donc si c'est comme
raymond un plan cul bien sûr capable non
c'est pas ça que j'ai dit j'ai dit au
début tous les mecs ils font les canards
tu fais des guilis en plan cuillère mais
dès que tu as fini oui barre dans le
frigo je cherchais une des rares
habitué des guichets de l'amour tu
restes avec la barre alors les chéri
doug août devant aux abois mais alors il
y a une astuce pour les femmes et une
astuce pour les hommes
l'astuce pour les femmes concerne le
dodo dormir avec une culotte c'est
dangereux
pourquoi alors oui il vaut mieux dormir
sans culotte parce que tout simplement
révolutionnaire que la flore qui est une
flore d'ailleurs autonettoyante qui est
très bien les lactobacilles mais c'est
pas les mêmes bactéries qui est dans les
yaourts c'est au dos a rien à voir c'est
bien là bas bah oui parce que si j'ai
envie de manger un yaourt la gamme
footballeur géant se foutait de la
gueule de faustine bollaert sur le sexe
voilà et zila qu'est ce qu'il veut dire
alors oui donc fait ça augmente
l'humidité la chaleur et sa faveur
police des vaches y donc vaut mieux
dormir une vaginite c'est quoi ce comme
une aisance et une inflammation des
irritations quoi que ce soit et ré c'est
mieux ça diminue la chaleur et la
personne d'accord alors donc il faut pas
tomber a qu'une culotte
sinon s'il ne veut pas dormir tout nu
parce que moi je sais qu'il ya des yéyés
des amis et des copains mois et défis
qu'ils disent oui moi j'aime pas du tout
nous tout nu parce que j'ai peur qu'ils
aient une bête qui voit là d'un terminée
voilà qui renferme on fait alors appris
jamal a qui pendent saisir on a observé
que les femmes qui ont ils sont pas
épilée avec des films très serré font
plus de plus le veau vache imminente du
régime
les acclamations des petites s'appelle
abus l'on doit cette sphère d'accord une
vulve hommage une itt de corse
on dirait vraiment c'est vraiment dire
est vraiment un truc dans attention au
soleil
j'ai des nouvelles de mener jusqu'à la
[Applaudissements]
toute fin et y avait toujours des
maladies w qu'il arrivait ensuite comme
ça ils arrivent à la plage et 10 et des
maladies bataille était serveur il ya eu
1 et après il s'est retrouvé sur elle à
ce qu'on appelle une vulvo vaginale
wilks a dit c'est pour ça que d'ailleurs
ces puces est plus vraiment à la mode du
string mais si les femmes veulent
vraiment porter des strings vaut mieux
prendre la taille au dessus que la
taille en deçà corps c'est toujours
important et laufon bl sinon c'est un
intérieur
ouais sinon faut mettre un jo wilfried
tsonga à tonga un tanga alors le
l'astuce pour les hommes notamment ceux
qui ont tendance à aller un peu vite au
lit pour retarder l'orgasme
il ya d'autres techniques que de penser
à sa grand mère le coq ring le coq
rabaisser dans le livre oui alors c'est
quoi alors c'est important parce qu'il
ya beaucoup d'hommes qui souhaitent
d'éjaculation précoce l'air si on sait
qu'on a un sur deux et on était ici vous
savez très fréquent et sa part two way à
part c'est sa part dans la minute c'est
infernal
c'est insupportable alors parfois le
désir a du mal à monter mais aujourd'hui
on a des parts pour les hommes comme
pour les femmes
il ya des points au niveau du corps qui
permettent d' allumer la libido
d'allumer le feu avec johnny et des pois
par exemple réflexe crémât steria
remonte lentement dans un axe haut de la
cuisse
on va dire le testicule qui remonte et
les grandes lèvres qui s'ouvre
comment alors c'est quoi l'astuce alors
l'astuce est très simple au moment où on
sent que ça va venir
il faut inspirer il ya eu un écartement
des cuisses à avoir à ce moment là quand
il faut écarter les cuisses avec aaron
eckhart
ça avec vous sentez comme à l'intérieur
bien évidemment alors ça et on reprend
la main comment on retrouve sa maman
mais non à lui arrêté ou lamar d'accord
on peut durer accord ah oui donc alors
vous avez ombrie vous êtes à l'intérieur
vous écarter les cuisses façon soul
balata les franges et là vous repartez
c'est çà et là normalement il ya un
écartement en fait on s'aperçoit parce
que parfois il ya des patients qui avait
pas urgence pour priapisme en faisant en
se mettant comme sakho puis plusieurs
fois ça retombe très bien et ben bercy
et bah franchement voilà les cinq
conseillers